dans les friteuses de la frite à mon
oncle les patates baigne dans l'huile de
canola mon oncle mario en utilisant
grande quantité facilement de sincère
600 litres par mois à une telle quantité
une hausse de prix est dur pour le
portefeuille à lui jacques annaud
effectivement les prix ont doublé pour
sa cantine le prix est passé de 1 dollar
18 le litre il y a quelques mois à 2
dollars 10 le transformateur mon boulot
à jour mon boîtier peut être deux fois
ce qu'ils paient à la même date l'an
passé pour son multicanal denis landry
approvisionne environ 60 pme au québec
en huile alimentaire
le blessé 40 % de hausse la matière
première le meilleur 6 65 % de hausse le
seuil aulas albinos est sain près de 80
% de hausse et que l'an passé j'avais
jamais vu chose et c'est au son du et de
mauvaise récolte de soya en 2020 en
amérique du sud
la rareté a provoqué une flambée des
prix sur les marchés boursiers c'est
sans compter l'augmentation de la
demande de biocarburants au québec on a
pris la décision de monter de 2 à 4%
d'ici 2025 la quantité de bio diesel qui
devra être mélangé au diesel est il pour
l'éthanol s'est passé de 10 à 15% d'ici
à cela s'ajoute le nouveau règlement
fédéral sur les combustibles propres qui
devraient entrer en vigueur en décembre
il vise à diminuer les gaz à effet de
serre en augmentant le pourcentage de
biocarburants dans les combustibles
fossiles non comme la principale
production d'éthanol vient du maïs massa
va mettre en concurrence les producteurs
de carburants avec les le secteur de
l'alimentation
une compétition qui hausse les prix
jusque dans nos assiettes ou g2 sino
prix cette année on love symbol
mais qu'à cela ne tienne pour celles qui
ne paient pas l'addition ici marie josée
paquet comme radio-canada mont rolland